the corona virus outbreak which as you
can see is spreading through the world
mainly China but elsewhere in the world
as well it's not just a major health
threat it's also causing serious
economic reverberations most obviously
share prices are down in Asia in the US
and across Europe so the footsie down by
2.3 percent today actually the biggest
fall since October Germany's DAX and
Frances cat-car on also down by similar
magnitudes and while Chinese markets
were closed for Lunar New Year
they were down 2.8 percent at the end of
last week oil prices are also down Brent
crude down below $60 a pound for the
first time since October why well it's
short it's because even if this outbreak
is pretty contained it's still going to
stop people traveling or trading and in
China more than 50 million people have
been prevented from traveling from the
affected areas which is a huge deal
because the Lunar New Year is usually a
big time for travel and for spending so
you've got domestic implications China
now the second biggest economy in the
world and any hit the growth is going to
reverberate around the globe domestic
spending actually accounted for 3.5
percentage points of total economic
growth the 6.1 percent in 2019 so you've
got the impact on Chinese tourism so
countries like Japan Hong Kong then
luxury and travel sectors they could be
very much affected you've got Chinese
tourists who spent a hundred and thirty
billion dollars overseas in 2018 and
when you have a look at the stocks which
are down you can see there's a clear
pattern so you've got travel related
stocks like British Airways owner IAD
down by five point five percent hotels
group intercontinental ihd it's also
four point nine percent lower in in the
luxury sector Burberry down 4.8% and
LVMH down three point seven percent now
ratings agency Standard & Poor's says a
global epidemic would impact investment
travel in tourism and industrial output
though some of the impact could be
offset by increased government spending
on health emergency services and
vaccines how big could the eventual
impact be well the songs outbreak in
2003 is estimated to have weighed 40
billion dollars off world economic
output it's too early to work out where
the corona virus could be more or less
costly but investors are clearly
concerned